hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel today I'm making a very quick
video which is being shot at my parents
house in Australia Audio is probably not
great but at least from that shadow you
can tell I've just turned the fan off to
try to make it better no I'm just
shooting on my phone because I wanted to
make this video super quick obviously
not a usual style video that I would
make but I didn't think I would have to
do this but then realize that I do so
here we are I have a new podcast it's
about video games who'd have thought the
first episode was actually on this
channel about a month ago the topic was
something about Star Wars Jedi phone
order almost being a very good game
which is a lot of what we spoke about
frankly the first episode is very Star
Wars II the thumbnail did say a new
podcast in it but then in my most recent
Q&A I mentioned having a new podcast and
I got a significant amount of comments
of people being like what new podcast so
I decided to make this video before
episode 2 comes out for all the people
who are asking questions about it so
that I can tell you what this podcast is
we just figured out a name I'm very
happy to reveal it to you all it is
called play watch listen it is a monthly
podcast where myself being someone who
has almost a decade of experience in
games media specifically Troy Baker who
you might know as a voice actor from the
lost of us and BioShock Infinite and
uncharted for Austen wintry who is a
composer known for journey and
Assassin's Creed a lot of video games
and then like Biffle who is a game
director who you might know for Thomas
was alone most recently John wick heck's
the four of us and it is going to be the
four of us every month I've had people
ask about that it's not gonna be
rotating it is those full people every
month talking about all of the games and
almost to talk about movies and TV and I
think probably just any kind of
entertainment that sits in the nerd
culture the episode that's about to come
out is largely about the game Awards and
the purpose of the Game Awards rather
than any individual game but it is those
four people every month talking about
largely the games industry from four
very different perspectives we went with
the title play watch listen
because you could see my camera shake
because I have it like propped on like
my mom had this like a big stationary
holder that I've then put my moisturizer
on top off and that my phone is sitting
quality it's called play which listen
which did take us a long time to figure
out because the logic was that you play
things that mic makes you watch things
that I make or that I write and you
listen to things that Austin and Troy
make though you could also argue that
you play the music that Austin writes or
you watch
Troy's performances but then it's also
about the things we have played watched
or listened to in any given month so it
kind of like spans ow
Koreas and the differences in those
careers but also the things that we're
talking about every month and this is
actually an extension of highlights show
that I used to make on this channel
every month where I would talk about
every game that I played in the month
and would also talk about some TV and
movies it was basically just me taking
that idea and pulling it into a podcast
with these three other people that I
really liked in really respect and I
knew that I had wanted to make this
podcast for a while after I stopped
making the highlights show as I used to
call it some people actually suggest
that I make it as a podcast by myself
but that didn't seem that fun and the
reason that this really all happened is
because I went to New York Comic Con to
moderate the John wick hex panel for
anyone who doesn't know that is a game
directed by Mike Bethel scored by Austin
wintry and the main antagonist is choi
baekho so those three had already worked
together on that and then i was flown in
to moderate that panel at New York Comic
Con that was about that game and I had a
lot of fun both on that podcast and then
out to dinner with those people and I
had also like at previous events been
out to dinner with Troy in Austin I just
had really interesting conversations
prior to this so Mike was the new
in this case but that panel was just
yeah three people talking about the
different things that they've done and I
felt like I learned a lot in a really
small amount of time but it was also
them just being very passionate and you
know similar sense of humor and
everyone's I would say opinionated of
extremely educated in their particular
fields very insightful really
well-spoken people so this is kind of a
thing and I had wanted to do anyway and
then I mentioned it to them in person
there and I think it actually maybe
texted Troy Austin about it at one point
even prior to that about the idea of us
solving a podcast together but then that
panel happened and I was like I'm just
gonna twit a DM the three of them and be
like I had this idea can we do it and
they all said yes and then we took a
month to figure out what the title would
be she's got art made which I'll show
you guys so the pilot episode was
originally only on YouTube because we
have to have a title and on to be able
to submit it to iTunes and Spotify and
whatever else so I have now done that
this show is definitely on Spotify go
subscribe play watch listen definitely
on iTunes go subscribe play watch listen
you can also just search a lot of PS and
the show will show up for you that way
as well it's also on stitcher but I have
had some minor problems there should
also be on Google Play Music I'll get it
on my heart radio soon and it will be up
for the last Friday of every single
month and it's something that I'm really
looking forward to doing as a passion
project I am NOT selling ads on this
podcast I've already gotten a lot of
office but I've chosen not to so it will
have YouTube ads running it which will
honestly not even cover how much it
costs for me to pay for the hosting of
the show so it's not going to profit but
I didn't really want it to because I
think sometimes making money off of
something they said less exciting and
this is a thing that is just is just
really fun for me because I like these
people
and then we just putting that it out
into the world so everyone else also
gets to benefit from that so that's cool
so yeah it should be episode 1 should be
available and everything
now episode 2 should be up Friday it's
gonna be Friday at midday Pacific time
the last Friday of every single month
and yeah I'll always make it so the
headline and the thumbnail indicate what
the general topic of the episode is
about of course but if you are watching
here on YouTube for the most part just
look out for the logo I'll probably put
it in the bottom left corner of the
thumbnail every time but uh yeah so when
I published the first episode some
people did assume that it meant that I
was leaving fun house for some reason it
definitely does not mean that it is
completely unrelated it's a non-profit
side project people have also asked
about my other podcast red lips orange
car that is coming back February is the
plan
I am closed I am just co-hosting it with
someone who was very busy and I we have
recorded some episodes but I've sort of
been delaying it because I want to make
sure we have a bunch before I go live
with the show because otherwise I feel
like we would run out because the two of
us have conflicting schedules a lot of
the time but yes know that this podcast
does not mean that that podcast is not
coming back or getting made but
otherwise to everyone who listened to
episode one thank you we got a ton of
use for episode one of something audio
was a bit low on it but I fixed it for
the audio feed so if you were one of the
people who didn't listen on YouTube
because of that I believe it is good on
Spotify and all she Spotify and iTunes
all students and all that stuff and I
think that pretty much covers it
obviously very informal video it's like
three hours until Christmas here in
Australia so to everyone who celebrates
Christmas Merry Christmas and I did want
to say you just while I'm home I that's
just super quickly I'm gonna leave a
link in my description to if you didn't
already know Australia is kind of on
fire a lot of the country is on fire
people have had to evacuate their homes
people have died so if I want to ask you
for anything this Christmas it would be
to donate to the Australian fire relief
I personally and completely safe my
family is totally fine some of my family
who's from Victoria has had to look at
the fire maps a lot to make sure the
house is okay but thankfully they all
yeah there isn't even any smoke where I
am it's actually raining right now it's
a storm outside so we need that but in
exchange for making a cool free podcast
if you want to throw a dollar in my
direction I would ask that you throw it
to the charity that I'm gonna leave in
the link below of course they have no
idea I'm doing this this isn't
affiliated response it in any way I just
wanted to throw to that because it seems
like a um kind thing to do on Christmas
Eve here in Australia
okay everyone let me know if you have
any more questions uh I will see you
guys on that video on Friday my